[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro 12 7 8 culture
30e émission de l'année quoi de mieux
que de fêter ça avec un numéro spécial
30 ans du parc france miniature les
équipes nous ont accueillis sur place
pour fêter l'événement au programme
aujourd'hui vous avez toujours rêvé de
parcourir la france en une journée ici
c'est possible nous retrouverons
frédéric elle alourdit lecteurs de
france miniature
il nous présentera le barc et son
concept le parc compte 117 monument soit
près de 2000 maquette comment sont-elles
réalisé et entretenu
reportage au coeur du métier de
maquettiste et puis le parc continue
d'évoluer il propose désormais aux
visiteurs des attractions encore les
expériences interactives
nous les découvrir dans ce numéro et
pour débuter cette émission je vous
propose un petit retour en arrière au
début du parc construit à elancourt
boulevard andré malraux le parc de
répliquer deux monuments nationaux en
miniature a vu le jour en 1991 à
l'origine du projet à deux passionnés
reportage à l'origine de france
miniature deux visages tout est parti
d'un projet d'étude au moment où les
parcs de loisirs devenait un vrai sujet
en france
thierry col qui a souhaité ancrer un
d'un genre différent
à l'époque étudiant en économie et droit
du tourisme france miniature est devenu
son cas d'application concret son
associé alain perrin ancien ingénieur
passionné de trains miniatures est
arrivé sur le projet par sa passion du
modélisme ferroviaire
le projet a été entièrement réalisée sur
fonds privés
un investissement de 20 millions d'euros
objectif promouvoir le patrimoine
architecture créer un lieu culturel et
récréatif
des urnes vides de promouvoir
d'expliquer le club de volley de mettre
en évidence la diversité des paysages et
autres régions françaises
le projet crée une carte de france 2 5
ha on y modelant les reliefs rivières
fleuves mail et océans à l'échelle 1 2
centièmes le projet a nécessité 18 mois
pour réunir le financement et les
autorisations administratives
on a lui aussi appelé 18 mois au parti
en casquettes mais à champ de creuser la
terre en c1 derrière mobiles et les
plages lancé en même temps la
réalisation de maquettes la réalisation
d'animations et 18 mois
à sa création le parc disposait d'une
équipe de maquettiste en interne pour
réaliser les villages et installer les
maquettes au sein de leur écrin paysages
et les monuments ont été réalisées à
l'échelle 1 30e par une soixantaine
d'artisans partout en france à l'époque
difficile à d'avoir des plans
opérationnels des bâtiments ils ont dû
faire des photos sur site des relevés et
tracer leur propre plan effectivement il
faut couler et donc d'avoir les outils
que les imprimantes et la contribution
des sont assistés par les temps qui ont
précédé l'ouverture l'équipe a travaillé
nuit et jour pour finaliser
l'installation le 25 mai 1991 le parc
ouvre ses portes
thierry col qui s en souvient jean s'est
inquiété de ce que le 6 et le
soulagement dans un effort au monde le
couple depuis les équipes
avec une charrette verso lui avec
toujours bon sur le s que des visiteurs
il y en a le parc en attire plus de
200000 chaque année depuis 30 ans il
fait désormais partie du paysage
culturel des yvelines mais aussi d'île
de france
au pied de la cité de carcassonne en
compagnie de fabrice la loure bonsoir
bonsoir
alors du coup vous êtes le directeur du
parc ici on retrouve donc 117 réplique
de monuments nationaux des réplique à
l'échelle 1 30e un concept qui permet de
faire le tour du patrimoine français est
ce que c'était sa l'adn du parc est ce
que c'est ça l'objectif
c'est ça la dn c'était ça l'objectif en
fait c'était vraiment d'avoir une
vitrine de la france d'être une grande
office du tourisme et dans l'espace
d'une journée de voir les plus grands
monuments français et donc du coup le le
concept la promesse comme vous disiez
est tenu depuis ces trente ans
finalement et oui alors on voit de plus
en plus de visiteurs découvrir le parc
ils sont heureux de retrouver les
monuments qui les ont vues soit en grand
et puis on espère en tout cas que ça
leur donne aussi la l'occasion il envie
d'aller les voir en vrai pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu et justement parlant des
monuments alors comment on choisit les
monuments a répliqué ici comme en israël
on les a choisis en fait alors le parc à
30 ans c'est notre trentième
anniversaire cette année
et en 1991 il a fallu faire des choix en
effet c'est les incontournables en fait
qui ont été posées au tout début c'était
pas très très compliqué et là on a posé
80 des plus célèbres monuments il ya eu
l'embarras du choix c'était il ya
évidemment un patrimoine très riche et
il s'est étoffé au fur et à mesure des
années pour porter à 117 monument
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
endroits où il faut faire des choix et
se restreindre puisqu'on est contrainte
par l'espace et d'hommes du coup là on
est sur un parc de 5 ha si j'ai bien
compris en regardant le flyer en fait
même le parc représente la carte de
france
c'est ça vu du ciel on a représente
exactement les contours de la carte de
france on a les fleuves les maires les
montagnes qui sont représentés aussi à
l'identique et cette carte géographique
a représenté au le nord et au nord
géographique donc toutes été respectées
comme la vraie elle il ya un hectare et
demi de mer également à qui bordent les
côtes de cette terre de france est donc
là on est sur le plus grand parc
miniature d'europe
on est sur le plus grand parc de
miniatures d'europe le premier concept
de ce type est né à maduro d'amilly
très longtemps il ya quelques dizaines
d'années mais c'est le plus grand parc
en effet en la matière en termes de
chiffres du coût pour france miniature
est ce que vous soyez bien à peu près
combien de visiteurs d'habitude un
parent on peut retrouver alors on
accueille chaque année près de deux cent
mille visiteurs et sa d'avril aux
vacances de toussaint avec évidemment
des périodes de pics certaines périodes
de cette saison mais d'avril à
toussainte deux cent mille visiteurs
très bien écouter merci beaucoup fabrice
alors d'avoir été avec nous merci je
rappelle directeur du parc et puis je
vois les anniversaires
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'aurez compris le parc compte 117
monument soit près de 2000 maquette
comment sont-elles réalisé et
entretenues 4 maquettistes et de travail
ici en saison nous vous emmenons au
coeur de leur métier avec ce reportage
regarder
[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'atelier mac est donc
comme à berne où la cabine de peinture
la zone de préparation peinture et
résines
c'est dans cet atelier que s'opère la
restauration des monuments de france
miniature
la plupart sont démontables et amener
directement sur place pour la
restauration objectif rénover les
maquettes produite il y a trente ans et
corriger certaines faiblesses une
activité au croisement de nombreux
métiers artistes soudeur ou encore
menuisier là bas on a différents
lapidaire qui sont en fait des systèmes
de ponçage abonde qui permettent de
générer des volumes juste à partir de
ponçage on va avoir une scie à ruban une
perceuse à colonne et puis quelques
machines un petit peu plus mécanique un
tour et une fraiseuse pour faire
certaines pièces de révolution ou satin
dessin particulier sur les pièces
l'atelier détient également tous les
stocks de wagons et de matériel roulant
du parc situé à elancourt une partie
essentielle du site 16 circuits sont
répartis dans le paysage trois
kilomètres et demi de voies ferrées des
trains qui parcourt 50km au quotidien et
travaille dix heures par jour
le matériel a été développé pour le parc
on a ici
ben justement le dernier train sur
lequel on est en train de travailler
alors c'est le trans europe express
c'était l'ancêtre du tgv avec une
volonté de pouvoir passer justement d'un
pays européen à l'autre chaque hiver
près de cinq maquettes sont restaurés en
profondeur cette année c'était le cas du
château de breteuil ou encore du château
de chambord dernièrement ce qu'on a
repris sur cette maquette c'est les
parties supérieures il y avait des
éléments qu'il demeurait en bois et qui
commençait sérieusement à souffler
abaissera des outrages du temps
donc on a refait toute la tour lanterne
avec ben justement son escalier en
colimaçon donc toutes les moulures et
c'est qu'il a fallu qu'il a fallu à
reproduire
et puis sur les quatre partie supérieure
du bâtiment les différentes tours qui
était encore en bois au total 2000
maquette composent le paysage de france
miniature
le parque continue d'évoluer et propose
24 attractions et expériences
interactives marianne et de dire bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes avec nous donc vous
êtes la responsable marketing et
communication du parc
donc quelle différence déjà entre
expériences interactives et attractions
alors attractions on va être dans un
espace ici à l'extérieur de la carte de
france dans lequel on va proposer aux
familles de profiter ensemble de
différentes attractions on va en
découvrir quelques-unes tout à l'heure
et les expériences interactives on les a
positionnés au fil de la balade dans la
carte de france parmi les monuments et
donc des attractions ici il y en a neuf
est ce qu'on peut donner des exemples un
peu de ce qu'on peut retrouver alors
dans les attractions phares vous allez
retrouver en intérieur l'expérience de
la salle du conseil de fort boyard ou
bien un parcours acrobatique qui se
situe dans une salle en intérieur avec
une vingtaine d'ateliers pour les plus
sportifs
et puisque je vous propose de tester
justin avec moi peut-être aujourd'hui
c'est le chat perché qui nous permettra
d'avoir un joli point de vue sur toute
la carte havas très bien joué aussi à
vous il va
donc là quel est le principe qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire alors le principe c'est
qu'on va se mettre en sécurité
et puis à la force de nos bras vaseux et
s'est emparé de moi là c'est ça en haut
de la tour pour avoir un joli point de
vue sur le parc
ok on peut plus de ces de faire un peu
un panorama c'est ça devant un point de
vue donc si on lâche pas d'acord on
reste en l'air d'accord vous sur la joue
ouais la fosse est gentil que cherchait
alors voilà c'est ça qu'on va jouer à
chat perché
on vient donc de tester la traction de
mais s'il n'y a pas que des attractions
il ya aussi des expériences interactives
y en a 14 ou est-ce qu'on peut aussi un
peu développé expliqué un peu ce qu'on a
ici on a alors ce qu'on a voulu proposer
aux visiteurs tant dans leur découverte
des régions de france
c'est comprendre une industrie une
tradition ou une spécialité et on va
pouvoir par exemple découvrir dans le
nord de la france pourquoi les beffrois
sont tous munis de cloche et on va
proposer une interaction très
sympathique pour les petits c'est un
grand trampoline sur lequel les enfants
vont être obligés de sauter le plus haut
possible pour pouvoir aller faire sonner
les carillons du nord et puis on a
également une expérience dans le centre
de la france qui plaît énormément aux
plus jeunes c'est un chantier de
fouilles préhistoriques où on se munit
de pelles de tami et puis en creusant
dans le sable on a la chance de
découvrir les trésors du passé
merci beaucoup mariane dire d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir je le rappelle vous
êtes responsable marketing et
communication du parc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
anniversaire dit cadeau et pour cette
année spéciale si comme le parent que
vous êtes né en 1991 joyeux anniversaire
le parc que vous invite gratuitement
cette année pour cet événement en commun
elles n'hésitez pas à profiter de cette
offre
invité spécial je fête mes 30 ans sur
présentation d'un justificatif
et puis autre particularité de l'année
le grand jeu anniversaire vous pourrez
tenter de gagner des places pour visiter
les vrais monuments français la
participation est gratuite via un qr
code a flashé sur place il faut ensuite
répondre à trois questions à gagner 150
billets pour découvrir les monuments en
grand un concours en partenariat avec le
centre des monuments nationaux jusqu'au
13 juillet c'est la fin de ce numéro du
7-8 cultures spéciales 30 ans du parc
france miniature
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi très
bonne soirée à tous et à bientôt sur tv
[Musique]